- I realize that success is fleeting.
As a fighter, you're only as good
as your last fight because
as soon as you win,
the clock starts ticking again.
That's what drives me to evolve
and improve every day
in everything that I do.
(upbeat music)
My name is May Ooi.
- [Narrator] May has mastered more things
than most will in a lifetime.
Her path to greatness started back
when she took up swimming as a child.
May would go on to compete
in the 1992 Olympics
in Barcelona, representing Singapore.
- I was swimming competitively
for about 14 years, and at the end of that
I was just really tired
of the training regimen,
the pressure from competition,
and not having a normal life.
- [Narrator] She went to college
and eventually medical
school, but then she stumbled
on a martial art called capoeira,
fell in love with it and
she mastered that, too.
That was her first step into MMA.
- MMA means mixed martial arts.
You will be fighting against an opponent
in the cage but you can use any form
of martial arts that
you're comfortable with.
I started with capoeira.
I have really good ground game in jujitsu,
so I like to take my fights to the floor,
and I like to finish my
opponents on the floor.
I think I've choked out
most of my opponents.
When I was training,
recreationally, I got really good
and a lot of people asked me to compete.
I refused to because I didn't want to be
in that competitive environment anymore.
But I met Harlow Gracie, who is royalty
in the martial arts world.
- [Narrator] Once he saw May train he knew
that she was destined for greatness.
He encouraged her to compete,
and so she did for five years,
becoming one of Singapore's best fighters.
And now May is taking time
away from competition,
and once again, mastering something new.
- We're gonna work on the jinga first.
I work with children from
two and a half to 12.
(calling out fighting terms)
I grew up in a middle-class family,
and I didn't have a lot of opportunities.
But through swimming and sports
I had amazing opportunities,
and I had a lot of doors
that opened for me.
Now that I have the means to
give back I like to give back
to Singapore and help grow
the sporting culture in Singapore.
(calm music)